monsieur bonsoir je vous propose de
commencer ce journal par ce rapport de
l'onu un rapport explosif qui implique
dans l'assassinât du premier ministre
libanais rafic hariri en février dernier
des hauts responsables syriens libanais
sont nommés entre autres le frère et le
beau frère du président syrien et le
président libanais lui même ce rapport
était très attendu on ignore l'ondé de
choc qu'il provoquera au plan politique
mais d'ores et déjà les réactions sont
vives
washington par la voix de condoleezza
rice passe assez complaisante
l'accablent demande à la syrie de rendre
des comptes et paris appellent damas à
coopérer dans l'enquêté bernard lebras
le magistrat et le secrétaire général il
est 13 heures hier à new york 17 heures
à paris
quand par surprise le rapport met lycée
revenus voici sa version imprimée dit
version officielle car il y en a une
autre dite version électronique diffusé
par erreur par les aurains les
ordinateurs de l'onu selon son auteur
nous nous sommes procuré cette version
des noms étaient barrées des noms de
hauts responsables syriens ont été
supprimés une certitude les deux
versions du rapport établi l'implication
syrienne avec la complicité de hauts
responsables libanais dans l'assassinât
de l'ex premier ministre en ces termes
signé des crèches maëlys il y à des
preuves convergentes un élément parmi
d'autres la fameuse camionnette blanche
bourrée d'explosifs filmer ce 14 février
par les caméras de circulation de
beyrouth selon un témoin auditionné par
maylis celles ci venaient de syrie et a
franchi la frontière libanaise ce lundi
14 immédiatement le ministre de
l'information syria a démenti sur al
jazeera faut dit il c'est un rapport
politique loin de la vérité et non
professionnels grands suspects aussi
selon le rapport le président de la
république libanaise en personne emile
lahoud selon mme ellis lahoud a reçu un
appel le matin du 14 février lui
annonçant l'opération il aurait été au
courant m'enfonce dit son porte parole
cet après midi
dans la version électronique les
accusations syriennes sont nominatives
maher assad et asef shawkat ont dessiné
d'assassiner hariri gravissime maher
assad et le frère peu ressemblant du
président syrien
assef chawkat et le beau-frère du même
président et le chef du puissant service
de renseignement militaire il ya dix
jours le président syrien avait prévu
c'est vraiment des syriens sont
impliqués ils seront considérés comme
des très sévèrement tu es déjà d'être
l'efs mélissa vu sa mission d' enquête
prolongée jusqu'au 15 décembre
mardi 25 octobre c'est à huis clos qu'il
exposera au conseil de sécurité ses
conclusions des shorts les cinq membres
permanents semblent divisés sur sanction
ou non guerre contre la syrie à beyrouth
maintenant des appels à l'aide